this example says find the coefficient
of the X cubed Y to the fifth term in
the expansion of 2x minus 3y to the
eighth power now you can imagine if we
were to write this 8 times and you have
to multiply it all out and combine like
terms that would take quite a bit of
time right so that's where the binomial
expansion theorem comes in and
specifically we're going to use that to
find out just that one specific term and
go ahead and find the number okay in
front of that X cubed Y to the fifth
term so first things first let's review
a couple things first thing is Pascal's
triangle and you can see with Pascal's
triangle that the rows begin with 1 and
they end with 1 ok so the rows go like
this right and then to get the term
below what you do is you add the two
terms above us we'll see how 1 plus 2
adds up to 3 two plus one adds up to 3
or 1 + 3 adds up to 4 now another way to
get these terms okay is to use this
combination formula so out of n items
how many ways other to choose R items
and the formula is n factorial over n
minus R factorial R factorial and so for
example if I'm down here on the fourth
row notice it starts at row 0 1 2 3 4
this number right here is actually 4
choose 0 so how many ways are to choose
0 out of 4 there's only one way to do
that and the same thing here this is 4
choose 1 4 choose 2 4 choose 3 all the
way over here 2 4 choose 4 so it's
always the row number choose 0 all the
way up through the row number choose
whatever row number you're on so for
example say we wanted to expand a plus B
to the third power what we can do is we
could say well let's go down here to the
third row and these are our coefficients
1 3 3 1 the other way to do it is to go
like this we could say 3 2 0 3 choose 1
3 choose 2 3 choose 3 then what you do
is you take the first term okay here a
and you go to the third power and you go
in descending order a squared a to the
first a to the 0 then you take the
second term B and you go in ascending
order so B to the 0 B to the first and B
to the second and B to the third and
then these terms are all added together
and you can go ahead and simplify and
those are going to be the terms in the
expansion
a plus B to the third power now I want
you to notice a pattern here that will
be very helpful see how we're on the 3rd
power we're also on the third row here
see this 3 2 0 notice how the second
term see the B B to the 0 power and see
how this is 3 choose 0 see how these
guys match same thing over here C 3
choose 1 B to the first power C 1 in 1
the other thing I want you to notice too
is that see how 3 plus 0 adds up to 3
that's the power here that's also the
row ok 2 plus 1 is 3 1 plus 2 is 3 so if
you recognize that pattern you can use
that to find a specific term in this
expansion so I'll show you over here so
for example 2x minus 3y to the 8th we
can see that our two terms are 2x and
negative 3y now I'm capturing this minus
as a negative 3y and then we want this
to be X cubes I'm going to make this to
the third power I'm going to make this
to the fifth power to give us Y to the
fifth
now notice we're on the eighth power so
that's the 8th roll through were to
expand this down Pascal's triangle this
is going to be 8 choose what do you
think goes here well remember the
pattern c 0 0 1 1 2 2 and so on so if
this is 5 this is going to be 5 as well
so now all we have to do is we're going
to use the formula over here for
combinations ok so 8 choose 5 that's 8
factorial over 8 minus 5 3 factorial
times 5 factorial and then we've got 2 X
cubed which is 2 cubed is 8 okay
negative 3 to the 5th is negative 243 Y
to the fifth now all we have to do now
is simplify all the numbers and that's
going to be our coefficient in front of
the X cubed Y to the fifth term so 8
factorial is really like 8 times 7 times
6 times 5 all the way down to 1 5
factorial is 5 4 3 2 multiplying all the
way down to one so you can see those are
cancelling 3 factorial is 3 times 2
times 1 which is 6 so you can see those
are cancelling so now we can see we have
8 times 7 which is 56 times 8 times
negative 243 so let's go to the
calculator here we've got 56 times 8
times negative 243 so that comes out to
neg
108,000 negative one hundred eight
thousand eight hundred and sixty-four X
cubed Y to the fifth now if they just
want that coefficient you would just
write down the negative one hundred
eight thousand eight hundred and
sixty-four so we're gonna do another
example but I know a lot of students
right now are preparing for the AC T and
the SAT especially in a math section so
I just want to let you know about my two
math review courses I got a huge AC t--
math review video course and a huge SAT
math review video course so check out
those video courses there's three free
lessons in each of those courses so if
you take those you'll get a lot of
benefit just from going through those
lessons and you'll get an idea about
what the other lessons are going to be
like as well and if you're interested
you can go on and purchase that and go
through the rest of those a lot of
students have reported back that they've
been able to boost their scores
utilizing those courses that I put
together so check them out otherwise
let's go to example number two and says
find the coefficient of the X to the
fourth Y to the twelfth term in this
expansion
okay so we're already little bit more
experienced now so we say hmm X to the
fourth Y to the twelfth well you can see
these are our two terms right here right
in our binomial by means two right so
five x squared and negative two Y to the
third I want this to be X to the fourth
that means this has to be two because a
power to power you multiply that's going
to give us the X to the fourth this I
want to be four because Y cubed to the
fourth power three times four gives us
twelve we're on the sixth row sixth
power so this is going to be six choose
and remember the pattern see how this is
three two zero B to the zero 3 choose
one B to the one this is going to be 6
choose 4 see how these match now all we
have to do is simplify this out and
that's going to be the particular term
that we're looking for so let's do that
so 6 choose 4 we use our binomial I'm
sorry our combination form the right up
there we've got 6 factorial over 6 minus
4 2 factorial times 4 factorial 5
squared is 25 X to the fourth negative 2
to the fourth is 16 y to the 12th and
let's simplify this so 6 factorial is 6
times 5 times 4 all the way down to 1 4
factorial is 4 all the way down to one
so those are cancelling and then 2
factorial
just two times one so this is 30 over 2
which is 15 times 25 times 16 X to the
fourth Y to the 12th now we're only
interested in the coefficient so we just
have to multiply those values out right
there so that's going to be 15 times 25
times 16 let's see that's 6,000 so our
coefficient in this particular example
is going to be 6,000 so I hope that
helped you how to understand working
with binomial expansion theorem a little
bit better I have another video that I
can link to too if you want to do more
problems with binomial expansion but
this is specifically focused on finding
the coefficient so I hope that helps you
understand a lot better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math videos on my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring and I look forward
to helping you in the future math videos
I'll talk to you soon